welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday the outcome of the presidential
election
is still a work in progress if big news
happens you will
hear it here we are closely watching the
vote tallies in four key states
nevada arizona georgia and pennsylvania
joe biden 17 electoral votes shy of the
270 needed to win and is leading in all
four
of those states both parties spent the
race trying to attract latino voters and
as maria villarreal reports
their choices for president are part of
a changing electoral
landscape just like the food coming out
of the kitchen at the patrila mexican
grill in houston
the presidential election is a hot topic
with latinos considered a key ingredient
not because
you see the color in my skin or my last
name is gonzales and you think we're
gonna go democrats
no owner friend gonzalez considers
himself tejano half mexicano half texan
but
all american he voted for president
trump back in 2016 but backed biden on
this election day
i'm a conservative i'm not a republican
and i'm not a democrat
country music fans over here make some
noise it's a similar message played out
in nashville
we traveled there in february before the
pandemic shut everything down meeting up
with country music newcomer frankie ray
when the dj played the very first time i
played in in alabama they saw me they're
just like that little mexican skinny
jeans
rey is a former police officer from new
mexico and draws in a conservative crowd
i voted for candidates on both sides of
the aisle at some point in my life
because i agree with what they're saying
26 million latinos were eligible to vote
four years ago but less than half cast a
ballot
which is why both parties tried to lure
latinos to the polls in 2020
there is a massive misunderstanding of
the political nature of latinos
cuban immigrant orlando sanchez runs the
organization texas latino conservatives
they distanced themselves from the
republican party and instead focused on
values like
education law enforcement and the
military which help
keep texas red when you trash the
military when you trash law enforcement
when you trash border protection
you're trashing the community and that's
where i think the liberal left
misunderstood texas a stark contrast to
the values of latinos in arizona
mary salamat has canvassed the state and
focused on one thing
empathy and it could turn the state blue
every single person we talk to it's not
just
you know we need you to vote this way
it's you know
i've suffered through this pandemic
you've suffered from this pandemic
this is how we're gonna win
[Music]
as the election wraps up frankie ray who
ended up not voting for a president
is trying to show latinos in a different
light i wanted to find a way to be a
voice for
mexican immigrants and people that
actually really break their backs and
work hard to contribute to
our country
[Applause]
[Music]
for cbs this morning saturday medea
villarreal
nashville